a new study by ancestry has revealed
that almost 1/3 of Brits admit they
don't know how they're related to some
of the people they sit around the dinner
table with in fact almost half don't
know their grandparents fool names the
former EastEnders star Larry lamb and
his son TV presenter George lamb are
backing up a campaign to get Brits
talking at the Christmas table and they
join in the studio I don't know about
you guys but by the point you know that
I reach the Christmas dinner table I'm
not exactly a hundred percent but I do
generally tend to know the relation with
the people that I'm sitting with what's
the explanation yeah it's really bizarre
it's right and also you know there's
seemingly there is there are Christmas
dinner tables around the country that
are full of great pregnant pauses where
nobody knows what to say next out plays
you've got a fight to get a word in
edgeways similar in the Paterson
household yeah so presumably I mean with
you guys and with with with my family I
know and the thing is so but that
funnily enough I did that program or the
program who do you think you are was
done on me so all of us have become sort
of serious nuts about trying to find out
where we come from what we're related to
who we are we found out about all sorts
of different bloods that we've gotten
inside us but what we want to know is
really how deep this goes you know where
do we come from I've just got feeling
somewhere I'm a caveman that you know
you know was from probably a far corner
of Scotland good well done
caveman no no no very sophisticated up
there but George the thing is there is
huge interest in programs like that you
know millions tuned in yeah but when it
comes to you know doing the legwork
doing the grunt work with with with our
own family it doesn't seem the work
we're either not in were either not
inclined to do or we think it's too
difficult you know what I think it's for
me anyway it's one of those things that
I've always wanted to do and for some
reason I put it off and put it off and
put it off and then we got this
opportunity to work with ancestry and I
was like absolutely I want to do that 1
million percent and I'm genuinely the
the best Christmas present I can hope
for is getting that letter explaining
exactly what our genetic makeup
what part of China we actually come from
exactly absolutely sure I mean I was
recognizing the Chinese accent
absolutely weird away but just in terms
of of what you can find out these days I
mean I have to admit you know what my
grandparents died when I was quite young
and I regret the fact that I didn't have
the opportunity to have a conversation
for example with my grandpa about what
he did during the war but but presumably
this information is out there if I want
to hear but it with the beauty of the
databases it links everybody's
information all of a sudden you're gonna
find a whole raft of cousins you didn't
know about you know and and a whole
backstory and history of perhaps your
family or family you know the family
once removed or whatever so you can get
some context and you can start if you if
you've got that interest in that
instinctive to follow it up all of a
sudden it's all there for you you know
tell us a little bit about Christmas
Shalem I mean what's on the dinner table
for starters you know dad did a show
last year with Gordon Ramsay where you
cooked Christmas dinner for how many 100
heroes I did that so we're not we're not
going to do that but like half a dozen
heroes probably traditional you know
like a big old a big old turkey or
something and and then not too crazy on
all the Truman's but enough enough not
to go insane you know a bit of
everything because presumably you guys
are you know you're pretty busy pretty
much all of the time I mean how often do
you get the opportunity to to hang it's
lovely
at Christmas you know and as you said at
the beginning sometimes things get a
little bit too stressful and it gets too
fraught and we get too caught up in the
whole you know all the madness of it all
and actually if you can find a way to
step back and remember that this is a
beautiful opportunity for you and your
family the people who you love and
actually care about the most we're more
important than all the nonsense that
you've been you know have filling your
time throughout the year this is the
moment where you get together and you
share and you exchange and how lovely if
you've got the oldies around the table
the old really you've got a bug in and
find out and you know who was grander
who was reserved the secrets about dads
grandma
was born in 1800 you know and and going
back to that and what she was about and
you know she was effectively she was a
Victorian right yeah without any shadow
of a doubt yeah she was but she was born
well before Queen Victoria died okay
very very brief for them so just running
at a time if you've got one bit of
advice for families who are perhaps not
so taught no chatty
talkative what would you say to them and
get mean party games or plenty of booze
what's the bolita start a Christmas
party on I mean I think the thing is
like start having a chat have a little
drink and get the thing going about
family Christmases and family families
think times together when you were a kid
yourself
that's really it questions questions
questions that's it you know asking
everybody likes talking about themselves
I mean the statistic is remarkable but
yeah it's a good message to send out at
this time of year ask your folks ask
your family about themselves and you'll
undoubtedly learn something about it out
laddie George thank you so much when it
comes very Merry Christmas